Good morning gamers we're back in Minecraft isn't right right Sven
There's one thing I've been wanted to try for so long in Sven go in the minecart cuz that would be pretty epic
Spend it, please. You're scaring me. You're scaring the kids Sven come down. Thank you. No stop. I
Get in spend
Get in spend get in the minecart. Oh my god
Oh
(Subtitle by *I am HeRe *in description at bottom)(sorry for any mistake)saaaaa  hahaha nooo.:):)
Wait for me Hey, I will that answers that question
Better stops ahead. Oh god is ena forever loop. Oh these stairs are awful. If you don't have the minecart so bad
I'm Cobb a god. Is there anything you can't do? How was that sweat? Did you like that you want to go again?
Okay, here we go spin go
Hey Bob say, all right while Sven goes on a little roller coaster we have other
Important stuff to do I think today I really just want to focus on building
because that's a big part of the Minecraft ship ship ship show sheets shop, and I haven't really done it and
I just really feel like doing it so
We're gonna build that something special today and I think it's gonna be pretty fun. I think it's gonna be pretty epic
Stop growing
I told you to stop
So we're gonna need some wool because we're obviously gonna decorate IKEA Tower as one of the things of course, of course
Why has not spend returned? Oh
Geez, I think literally all my mine carts are down there Oh
God's man watch out
Oh
Eat eat eat eat damn. I
Hate them ruin my flooring and they hurt Sven. I can't do this
How can you live just to give other people pain?
All right, we have the minecarts. All right. So now we push then
And then this will push
Here we go
We're under attack
No, no, no, no
You can't eat me he wet again
So then can you stop I?
mean state staying there be a good boy, and I put this and we
Yes, yes. Yes. Yes. Yes
All right, that's enough fun that's enough fun for now Finn
Just keep feeding Sven. That's all we need to do remember kids if spend eyes playthrough over
No more I refuse to play
Okay, so I got this ready post. I said you can make letters out of banners and I'm like, okay
That's epic. So I'm gonna try and do that
It could be another troll who knows at this point, but I'm willing to get trolled if the result is what I want
Okay, we need four of them and I made five for some reason. I know Sven
I know and then when you yell the yellow die, so if I do this, can I do letters? How do I do letters?
Through this it must be spent I swear to god you're gonna give me a heart attack sit down sit boy sit
How you doing today? Water sheep. Wake up. What a shame like this. This is nice. Yeah, it is
Okay, cool, and then a K wouldn't that truly be?
And like that and then like that
Like that I think you know where this is going, yeah
And then an e wouldn't naturally be we're gonna put that on top of
There I think I think that would look good. It won't be symmetric there though
Cuz it's only three wide is there anywhere there's four wide I need cemetry
One two three four, that's five and then it goes to three. Ah
It won't be symmetric. Okay, I got it. I got it. This is how we'll solve this problem
It's it's a little confusing one needs to enter to know which level you are on. Okay, I'm sorry
Oh god, I should not bring fan up here so bad. No, I keep forgetting see. Oh
God if sweat balls
So
Yes, ah
Okay, okay all right now
God sent for the love of God do not fall down from here. What are you
Yes
That's awesome
What do you think sweat? Okay, that worked that really well
IKEA Tower so beautiful. It's going across the clouds
So and remember if you're ever lost just look for a Kia Tower and you'll find your way back home. Okay?
How are you doing today? You're against Megan. I'm not talking to you talking to you. Yeah, yeah, you just want to write everything
It's fine. Okay, so then get in the boat because we have a new thing you do need to do
So basically I want to build another house. I want to build not just any house, but a japanese-style house
That's right. Gamers. Are you excited for this Sven? I think you are nobody PD PI. I want to be able to definite out
Like the game has seized achacha a Kasab whatever
Would and it looks really cool and I'm like that looks nihongo is freak. We're gonna build something out of that
So yeah, let's just let's just big Sven. I mean a bit build
And let's see what happened where did virgin?
toad
Turtle go. All right, maybe virgin toad will come back. Alright, then. We'll make steps here Bing bong Bing bong bong save the earth save
materials in Minecraft
Okay, so I need to cut the stone get pretty I want it to be pretty I want my house to be pretty judge me
Sue me
Maybe I'm maybe I'm thinking a little too big here, but sometimes you got to think big to go small big five five
It's five six. One, two, three, four, five six seven. Luckily. I have my
Looks like we need to do some digging
Oh, I dig like the wind. Oh my god. I forgot something. Okay, we'll do that when I get back
I don't know what it is just building in Minecraft is so relaxing. It's not right Sven. It just makes me happy. That's right
as you guys know I
Love Japan, and I don't care if you call me a weed. I'll build my Japanese house
Okay, that's a pretty cool runway. That's pretty epic. All right, let's go back. So and it's dark
It's sleep time hard day's work. This is a pretty historical moment gamers. I
Have a lot of diamond
But I haven't really made a level three diamond pickaxe
right, everyone keeps complaining that I don't use my diamonds, but then sums Barnhardt efficiency for
Okay game
Sound likes men got hit
Okay, if bishops before what is efficiency do oh, woe it gain fortune three on breaking three. Oh
My god, that's that big man. I can't wait to test this out. I just test it out a second. Don't talk to bait
All right, that wasn't that cool ah
Sorry Sven you have to swim. Yeah. Hey look you're not a bad swimmer. Oh, he's so happy
Look at this a cashier would it's looking so Smacks
So stylish right Sven
oh, yeah, I
Don't know what I'm doing this could turn out really badly. We'll see
Listen, it's all about the respect. So and remember that never forget it
You know, this would be a lot easier
Help me bad, I wanted to look pretty I guess this is a good time for me to share some like embarrassing stories
Stuff like that. There's a lot of people a lot of people seem to think my first video was in Minecraft video
So everyone is like, oh my god, you should go back to your roots and play Minecraft
I never actually like played Minecraft. I think I had one series. Okay, that was it. Like okay. Sorry. I got it wrong
Basically, my first video technically that is up on my channel is a Minecraft video, but it wasn't the first video
I uploaded I have a lot of videos that I just took down because I think they're just so cringy and I don't like them
I mean I could probably put them back now. I don't really care anymore, but
I do I yes, they're cranky. None of my videos can be cranky. Oh, no, I misspoke
basically
The actual first video that no one has ever seen. I've tried desperately to find it
I can't find it
The very first video that I ever recorded was a Minecraft video and it was like before minecraft was getting popular
I know I keep like ooh, I'm a veteran but literally no one played
Minecraft at this point and
I thought okay. Well, wouldn't it be cool to become like a Minecraft?
And here we are nine years later
Well, basically I thought it was so weird to record a video like that whole concept was just so weird to me
No one recorded videos at this time. It wasn't like Let's Plays wasn't popular people weren't doing minecraft stuff
And I was just so weirded out by I'm like, who am I talking to I have literally no audience
Am I supposed to talk to people like there is one I guess it was really confusing and weird to make videos
When no one else really was all right minority. I would say compared to now it's like people
Aspire to be youtuber well as before
People didn't really know what importance that was my point. So I actually upload it to this website
That like posts videos and I thought okay cool
I'll just ask these guys to help load the video and they'll take care of it
And then that that way I'll actually have an audience if they post it
But obviously they never posted it and I couldn't find the video so I don't have it anymore
But my very very very very first video I have ever recorded was indeed a minecraft
Let's play that's right. That wasn't really what I was getting at. My main point was that oh god. This won't work. Will it?
Ah, Frankie have I built this all on a step wrong? Ah
Oh, maybe we can make like an optical illusion like these are on the right floor
Just places in front and then we get the effect that we want
Genius I also liked when I was starting out doing YouTube videos
I was in a really weird time where I didn't know what I was I wanted to do. I talked about this a lot
So I I applied for like different jobs and stuff like that and one of the jobs I actually applied for I've never told anyone
This ok. This is super secret. I applied for a job at Mojang
Mojang if you leak my email I will tell you I probably said something like hey, I know Photoshop you want to hire me
Mojang is the creator of Minecraft basically and I remember when they they got really big they they sent out a
Like a Twitter's thing or something saying like, oh, we're hiring you can apply and I'm like, alright, that would be cool
I'm from Sweden. It's a Swedish company. I didn't get the job
Imagine if I did that we're getting under attack Spanish. We're building a Japanese house and you're not allowed I want to create like this
Typical Japanese door effect. I don't really know how to do it
I'm hoping that it will look good with like a trap door. Yeah, that looks good
Oh, yeah, this is a gamer moments when this is starting to look epic starting to look Nihon
I think yes, not you missed out man could have made epic games together. I don't hate it. It looks a bit
Alien, I don't know but actually, alright. We need more trapdoors. I
Don't really know how to do the ceiling but we'll figure it out soon. So
These doors will not actually work. I know I
Like it I like it we went in some midsummer the movie yesterday which is base of this Swedish tradition that we have oh
Boy, was that a trip now? That was a film?
Undeniably a film I recommend it was good. I love how all the colors come together ceiling time
Do I build a ceiling in white or a gray or a cache up now? This is a really gamer question
I know that you've been thinking it throughout
Its beauty by gonna make it Alka. I'll try the chords. First is I think I can make them in slams. I
Know I know I'm crazy. I'm crazy Sven game. I gotta do what give me gonna do stone will look good, too
They could all look good. Okay, I have an idea. Why don't we just test it will test everything now?
What looks better I think the stone I think the stone looks better it ties it all nice together, don't you agree Sven?
I just love
Japanese architecture, it's so different from anything else
How will I do that typical effect where it goes up? Right? I mean that look doesn't look bad
Thanks, man. No no. Oh
Thank god. All right, I'm going back to sleep gamers. Let's go back and take a nap spin. Yes. See that's yeah, that looks good
Gamer moment right there. Gosh, I didn't think the ceiling would be this complicated
It's really tricky building ceilings. No one talks about that in Minecraft my god
Why am I spending so my time on?
The problem is I can't just back up and look how it looks like I have to look at it
At the micro scale and then get a mic macro picture of it. It's really tricky tricky D
Get off my house. My Japanese house is for me only. Ah
Let me build this a time god I just want to build it
Building houses in Minecraft is relaxing they said okay. It's looking pretty neat
I think it's all about that details now the fun stuff. We're gonna make some fan nourishment. It's gonna be epic
It's like red banners could look cool. Maybe black banners could look cool. Maybe like a lot of stuff to look cool
I know what I'm doing. No, I don't I just hope it looks cool
Oh my god, turtle virgin turtle is back guys. Oh I have together. I'm trying to build
Oh, yeah. Yeah, that's what I want to do
I'm trying to build over here guys, please
Oh god, we're bouncing we're bouncing. So apparently you can ride these
horses underwater, I don't know if that's
True. Sorry Savannah. I gotta check this out. Okay. Alright
That's kind of Awesome. What? Okay, you got a sink though. Oh god. I'm actually drowning
Can you not drown me, please? Thank you. Now. What color scheme am I going?
Plus, I have a lot more red and maybe I'll do like a cool pattern. Oh, yeah, that's gonna look good
I was like here barging toad
Okay, so I need to see grass. I think you use shears to retrieve it chip-chop
Chip top six top chip top. Why is the horse eating it lit?
what an idiot ah
Alright, it's a secret. Alright virgin. Oh my god, he found someone
He found someone okay, this is perfect. Yeah, follow me. Akima, sha
Tata
So we need to get them saying but we have sand here oh, this is just perfect
Come here guys
Why are you so hey, did I tell you to stop? Oh god. No, you have a girlfriend. Come on. Come on
It's like slightest get up. Get up get up
Did I tell you to stop I need you to eat it?
So you two can Frick I need your helmet from your babies. Dude. I got to say bone horse is pretty good
Like he doesn't disappear and stuff. No one leaves these beach until you two have friend
Let that be clear now. Our was sight. Yes epic mansion. Alright, we're gonna be there
Great now we ran out of fence. I hope you guys are happy. Oh, yeah, another thing apparently
name
There's another Easter egg. If you name your animal dinner bomb, I think can I do that?
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. What do you eat? What are you course? I'm so stupid. I have to put a name on it first
My anvil disappeared this better be worth it, where'd he go? Nothing you could see. Oh my
Oh
My no I ruin him better bode this history
Why did you tell me to do this
I'm so sorry. The nine year olds told me to do it
I'm already dead. And you Jesus? Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, this reminds me
There's another thing I want there's so many things to do in Minecraft. Literally this let's play could go on forever. I'm not even joking
Okay, so with nine slime balls this hook better be worth it. I can make a slime block and then with a slime block
Where it's meant I want sin to see this then you have to come look at this why is he upside down? I don't know
He's like don't tell me I don't think oh my god. I'm so ticklish
Stop it. Stop it. Are you? Oh, yeah go in the pool spin
So apparently if I put this I will be able to bounce watch this thing
Yeah
Okay
So then you try it come here dinnerbone
Please damn it looks pretty epic from a distance. I'm not gonna lie. Alright, are you two ready to make some babies?
I think this one is already pretty does that make any sense? You're already pregnant you where's your babies then?
Maybe it's your brother or something
God he's like that's my cousin. What's wrong with you main? Well, I guess virgin toad will be forever a virgin turtle
I keep saying toad
You're gonna be here. You're gonna be alone for a long time. I'm sorry. I don't know how to break the news for you
I know it looks amazing Sven. I know I worked hard on it, but it was definitely worth it. When are we moving in?
Well, we got to do the interior in stops when you see it's not completely it just said
What kind of pattern can we do on the banner? That will look cool? Okay. All right, wait here virgin
Well said, you gotta come see this
The miracle of birth. Is that what I think it is. I knew you were pranking. He's all about
What is this
Yeah, oh my god, I can't wait for them to hatch I'm don't worry I'm not gonna do anything bad
Yo, let's get the virgin over. Oh, we got to protect them
We got to protect the eggs Oh God and the Sun is going down. Oh my god. I'm freaking out
I'm freaking out but look I
Got a protector. I'm so proud of you turtle. Oh
God, it's a raid
Put the kegs at all cost. I didn't think you had it in yet
What can I say? I was wrong. You're gonna smell again. You better protect those eggs
So back, basically the zombies will attack and stomp over the exit they get the chance
So we got to make sure that these eggs are under our Khan Chaka laka, all right, I'm gonna clear out these sand
No back off
Back off defend the eggs at all cost
I hate them not a creeper. Not a creeper. Not a creeper. I'm done
If the egg is cracked I'm gonna just swim bone cow yet don't mind me I'm just drowning is whatever
Oh my god, I protected the egg. Oh
Thank god. I mean I lost 30 levels
But I've protected the eggs rights men, all right, how is the baby's going
How are the babies doing so I could be crazy, but I think if you combine with bone meat?
you can actually make this go faster and
Yeah, I'm crazy. Okay, that doesn't work. Sorry. Sorry. I I'm not touching them. I swear. I'm not touching them. God. I love this shovel
I'll have to repair it
Okay more sand more area - Frick am I right ladies?
Why did I say that? Okay, so all right now we're just gotta learn this either the Virgin toto. You can't just have people
Time with a girl and then just leave her. All right, you got to take responsibility now virgin turtle. Oh my god
Why did the other one? Okay, what are you two doing? Come here get up?
Look how badly he wants that the other one made it up
Here making another baby
Just making another baby you
Can't just make it at the same spot you soon
Whoa
Childbirth come back and take responsibility
This guy just freaks and bounces
push push push you and push push push push push push push
there will be no more freaking and bouncing there will just be freaky -
ha ha ha
Better I have you trapped now. Hey, calm down. Calm down. Calm down. Calm down. Calm down
Alright your bit your bit aggressive over there. I
Don't know what this is. I don't think this is I think he might be
Maybe
Having kids are stressful guys. I don't know if you knew this
Oh my God, look at his aam be no no
I'm sorry
I'm furious
Alright there's only one thing to do and that's more freaking oh you die
Miracle of birth be born I
Want that Turtle helmet dude certain zombie fortress because I want to blow that thing up. Okay. I'm with they're gonna pay for
What they did
This is not okay should have protected you guys but I didn't I
Let you down I could be crazy and this could be the worst mistake of my life
But I think if you have silk touch you can separate the eggs. Oh
god
Yes
It work turtle egg is mine and then we can place them away from each other and that way they grow
quicker
Look at that alright more frickin, but I tell you to stop more frickin. Meanwhile I can build my house
Yeah, I didn't see you there little schmuck
I'll kill all of the younglings now. You killed my younglings. I kill your younglings. Usually I feel bad about it, but not anymore
This is how wars are made
This is how they start I tell you to stop freaking I don't think so what
What?
what how
Science does not allow this
To build my god damn Japanese house keep fracking
Sven
Hurry spender. Look look look the miracle of life has happened Sam. Yes. Oh,
my god
You've gotta come see this one. Hey, let me open up for you, buddy
Look they're tight. They're escaping. Oh
God we gotta wait. Wait, wait, wait guys. No
Outside I
Think not oh god, I'm wasting precious material
Do they need to go to the water addict a climb that makes no sense? Push push. Sorry little dirt those
Push push I'm proud of you Virgin toad. I'm drunk them proud of you. What can I say?
I didn't think you had it in yet. There will be no baby turtles escaping on my watch
Sven buddy, it's fag. Stop Spence op that oh god I got
In front of merging toad, I can't believe it what an absolute elephant. Alright gamers
This is it for this week's episode of Minecraft. Alright, it's not it's not finished, but I'm a pretty pleased with it
I think it's it's gonna come out pretty nice. Isn't that right Sven?
I know this wasn't the most eventful episode but next time we'll get on some adventure because I have a woodland
Explorer man see you tomorrow gamers smash like and buy merch
buy
What you never played super simulator
You know, it's fun right I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not not convinced yet. Okay
I'll cut you a deal the game is available for free and that's a great price